here's what's going on at the movies  blasting into theaters is the sci-fi  action film Star Trek beyond which finds  the crew stranded and battling a  ruthless enemy experienced Star Trek  beyond in IMAX 3d let's make some noise  Mannie Sid Diego and the rest of the  gang are back and embarking on a  hilarious new adventure in the animated  family film ice age collision course  this is the guy who's going to save us  based on a viral short film lights out  tells the terrifying tale of a woman  haunted by a supernatural entity that  only appears when the lights go out and  finally let's find out what's hot in  theaters this weekend with this week's  fan tissa patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket